what are we looking at so this is a
frequency table right it's a table that
tells you about a particular kind of
dollar in this case it's doctor's visits
and how frequently those things happen
right so these are different numbers of
times that the doctors been visited and
this is the number of people who've
visited the doctor that many times right
so there are five people who didn't see
the doctor at all in that hole I think
it's a three month career okay there's
six people who visit him once in that
season and 14 people crew and three
people who and so on okay so frequency
frequency is how many people or how many
things have gotten this score right so
this is number of visits it could be a
test score it could be an amount of
income it could be anything okay so
let's have a bunch through this right
you can see that we first want to know
this is part a how many people have
seven so this is pretty easy yeah that's
right all I need to work out is the
people where this column here right
frequency is people so I'm just gonna
turn them up alright let's just quickly
go down 511 help me out 25 28 33 34 yep
so that's just me adding up this
frequency column 34 I think that's what
I said
okay so that's how many people are
surveyed in total and that will come in
handy when I'm working out the mean
later on cuz I've got to work out the
average divided by the total number of
people the median
how do I work out a median from this if
there are 34 people in total right
where's the middle of that do you
remember we thought a little bit about
this before yeah okay so I want these in
like you know ascending order
I kind of already have an ascending
order in that it's 0 1 2 etc so that's
really good okay but I need to know
which score or scores are the median
Nathan what do you suggest
okay so a reasonable guess is here right
like before I've even done any
calculation because it seems like
there's the most people there
it is kind of roughly in the middle but
how would I be certain how would I go
through a process where maybe the dad is
not so obvious any takers
yeah Brenda okay yeah
so you might remember if I had a set of
scores like this eighteen nineteen
twenty three forty forty-one okay now
obviously you can all see which one the
meeting is because I've given you a nice
small set but you could get there by
crossing off crossing off cross you're
crossing off and then what's left right
and the only reason why that's a bit of
a challenge here is because number one
will take a while number two like these
numbers might not match up night nicely
right the one in the five they don't
match up do that once I do this it's
like do I go bit into here how far am I
going here do i it gets a little unclear
okay so exactly right so here's what I'm
going to suggest right do I have an odd
number or an even number of scores I'm
an even number of scores so if I have an
even number of scores the meeting is not
any particular score it's halfway
between the two middle scores you see
that okay so how do I know which ones
are the two middle ones yep so once I've
got these I'll take the average of those
so what I want yeah right for six scores
is between three and four thirty four
scores I'm even gonna write this down a
median is between which two scores now
to help you see six scores if I divide
by two that's to get halfway right that
gives me three and then I go one forward
that gives me the next one okay so if I
divide this by 2 I get 17 very good 17
school and the next one which will be be
18 school so now I can count now I can
count I don't have to worry about
crossing underneath it right so there's
five there's 11 clearly the 17th scores
going to be in here as we
kind of anticipated right so 17th and
18th calls are both gonna be healing -
so he says no the mean okay so does
anyone remember by the way there's a
symbol for me you'll remember it it
sound
I'm X with a little bar over it so you
sometimes will say that how do we work
out the mean he's where we're gonna need
this extra column dinky all right jazz
FX the frequency x however me visits
there were right so I'm going to have to
multiply these numbers across to get the
total number of visits that the doctors
done right so help me yeah 0 by 5 0 1 by
6 ZX 2 by 14 and ok fantastic so I want
all the visits that the doctor has
gotten so just like he are I'm gonna
need to add these up okay has anyone
already worked it out 637 you one okay
so that's how many tons of doctors we've
visited all up so I can stay
71 visits in total divided by what again
how many people did those visits right
so what do you get let's actually get
like a decimal for that can we get you
know like one decimal place B to point
yeah good I'm getting um I'm getting two
point zero eight they haven't told us
what to approximate so I'm just gonna
leave that as it is does that match what
we expected it does right the vast
majority of people have visited twice so
that's why this number is kind of close
to that it's a bit higher than two cuz
you have all these people you even have
a few people you have one person who's
got a whole load of times four times
more than an old person okay so we're
almost finished now mode that's an easy
one most common
which one's got the most common it's
this guy right because that's the most
frequently noticed one mode is also two
and last one also simple question range
is about top takeaway bottom right so
it's eight eight takeaway zero I think
it's helpful as well
to write down that it's takeaways Europe
even though it doesn't change the number
because that shows you know where range
comes from it shows you know it's
composed of these two numbers